foreign
[Music]
cast number 16.
brought to you courtesy of Jocko
Productions and today we're joined by
our 16th guest who was a member at
McPhee SOG he was on RT Idaho for a
short period of time and this isn't part
of our ongoing series I'd like to
welcome to the show today well I knew
you as Captain Michael Byrne who went on
after SOG to have a rich career and we
had some time together at the at CCN at
command and control North which was in
Da Nang and that was the northern base
for the Mac V Saga operations that went
on the secret War for eight years Mike
welcome to the show sir thank you sir
and uh you know you you and I got to
know each other through I guess Lynn
black first because you had known Lynn
and then um we had a special mission
that we needed a high tech technician to
take with us on a Target
and uh you wound up training with us for
the mission this is in April of 1969 at
CCN and at that point you were working
in S2
yes I was in the SD shop so for our some
of our viewers S2 was the intelligent
side of things and uh this is after I
escaped from Project gamma down in four
chords indeed
and so
um with each of our saw casts we always
interview people that have been involved
in SOG and I think your story is
fascinating because there's a lot of
confused about Gamma project Sigma
project and worthy and sagarnot so maybe
in your case if we could go back if you
want to start at the beginning a little
bit on that because there's some
fascinating sidebars to that whole part
of your life before you came up the sog
and uh how do you so maybe we should
start with you came into the army decide
to become an Officer and a Gentleman
and then take it from there and you wind
up a gamma I was commissioned in AIS out
of college oh is that right AIS people
say what what the heck is it yes Army
intelligence and security was a branch
before Mi was created like ASA was a
brass before they talked about anise
yeah okay okay sure and so um
when I came on board I was trying to get
to SF
but AIS Branch couldn't get any quotas
for it so they said okay we'll send you
to Ranger school and send you to
Airborne school and you can be quiet and
you know AIS was really looking for
bonafides with with the the combat arms
right you know you can't have a bunch of
of nothing
uh guys running around trying to talk to
to Battalion commanders and so forth and
have any credibility so you know you you
get the ranger patch you get the
Airborne patch and you
that get that gets you in the door but
again you're very modest here you went
through ranger training
and this is after Airborne training yes
right so you get your five jumps in
Airborne training which is a three-week
training course and then at that time
ranger training was not no slouch
uh is it now no
yeah I was telling somebody we were
talking about Dahlonega and I said yeah
I don't live too far from there now and
I can remember standing out in the Yona
River I think it was in ice water in the
middle I was a December Ranger oh and uh
learning to tie knots they had these
posts out there in the water and so we
stood in the water and froze our butts
off yeah indeed there's no one like that
so anyway yeah graduated went to
infantry officer basic
um had a short stint with the Mech
infantry battalion at Fort Benning and
volunteered for Vietnam I said you know
you get me out of here
and I got to get some place that makes
more sense Vietnam was better than
Georgia Vietnam was better than MEC
infantry at Fort Benning yes yes so
so anyway
um
they they assigned me to Vietnam and
for
further assignment to this detachment
b57
of fifth Special Forces Group
and Detachment b57 was uh project gamma
and Gamma was a um an intelligence
operation
and what they did was they they took CIA
trained case officers
people who had learned how to recruit
agents and you know do all that did you
have to learn the language too or did
you have interpreters no no I had an
interpreter okay my languages were
French and and Russian yeah my foreign
language is English yeah
I get that normally after a couple of
beers yes so
so anyway I showed up down there this
this organization was in a building that
was back behind the Dairy Queen
at uh at SF headquarters at fifth group
headquarters oh you know what that that
Dairy Queen was for me one of the most
psychologically damaging moments of my
life at the end of my first Tour of Duty
I'm going home no at the end of my
second tour Duty I was going home and
doing Beach guard and the NVA bombed
that place it blew up the ice cream
parlor where did they do that I don't
know but all the arrests had to go
downtown for their ice cream it was
really I'm sorry but go ahead so you're
behind it it is
so anyway I go in there and I I get the
intro and they said we're gonna send you
down to a special forces a camp
a421 the four meaning four core right
yeah number 21 of yeah four core
which was an old French Fort that was
right on the Cambodian border we could
look out and see Cambodia from from the
uh from the the camp from the camp
perimeter yeah it was built on a little
Hill
probably you know 300 feet 400 feet tall
yeah and we had a 106 recoilless rifle
up on top of it and this part of four
core was just flat flat absolutely flat
and it was covered with water
and so you know we ruled anything that
was within our
with yeah our eyesight as long as we
could get permission from the The
Province guy to to fire oh we got enemy
in the wire can we shoot yeah
one of the vagaries of
of service there anyway
so they sent me down they put me in a
jeep I'm
uh first lieutenant with a couple of
months in service and
um
they give me a Jeep and a portable photo
lab
and a
money box that had
a bunch of money in it
and they sent me down there and said
okay go down and set up an operation
here at uh a421 so I went down to
introduced myself you know had that
Green Beret and the whole works only my
name was Doucet
Mike Doucette Doucette was my best
friend back in high school sure and so
you know I react to the name you always
want to if you give an alias you want to
keep your first name right because you
immediately turn around when somebody
says hey Mike and
um you know and and so anyway so I got
down there they gave me a bunker
big concrete bunker that used to be the
the command center for the old French
Detachment that was there
and they
and then they I'm laughing because I
tapped the table and that's a No-No
indeed so uh they said you know recruit
a principal agent and start running
folks across the fence into uh Cambodia
and report back on what's going on
because this is the the ass end of the
Ho Chi Minh trail sure and um
so uh I did and I tried to do the
traditional vetting and all that good
stuff and finally got one
and um
we were about to start doing stuff and
headquarters got well I digress
um
I thought that if you're in a special
forces a camp
you can't stay in your bunker
all day 24 hours a day you know and not
go out on operations when everybody else
is going out on operations
so I went out on operations
and I wound up with a couple of purple
hearts from that and uh
you know but it was it was all good I
mean good learning and yeah and you're
developing good Intel along the way but
headquarters didn't like the idea you
know of you and officer in the field
you're out there going around having fun
shooting stuff up
and so they said you know stay
at home yeah don't go out and do this
stuff so anyway uh I said three bags
full and promptly forgot the
instructions and unfortunately I went
out on an OP we got put in on the top of
a nearby mountain and as we were coming
down
the only path down from the mountain
which I advised against us taking we
were supposed to be lifted off by a
helicopter but the helicopter got
canceled for some reason they said yeah
just walk down so we walked down and we
walk through uh
Claymore Ambush oh and these Claymores
were like you take a top of a 50 gallon
drum right and you cut it off and then
you pack the inside and shape it
and uh we got we got hit with those on
the way down as careful as we could be
we you know it's just stuck that's oh
yeah get out of there you got to walk
down
and um my principal agent got cut in
half basically he took a oh he took one
right in the gut
and uh so then I had to report to the
headquarters that the principal agent
was was uh
no longer with us and they said did you
go out on operations I said uh yeah they
said okay
get a collection effort going now you
know yeah your time is looted if you
don't get it done the you're gonna
be working in the mess hall or something
so I went out and and I knew that there
were some locals who wanted to make some
money
so I trained them equipped them sent
them across the border with a bunch of
money
and um what I didn't realize what the
was that the cambodians were very
fractionalized
they had all these different factions
that that wanted to kill the other
factions and so forth like that and so
uh when I sent them across
to go spy on the the Khmer Rouge and so
forth
what they did was they decided this was
a time to have a little war now that
they had guns and all the other stuff so
they went in and they went on a rampage
across the border well they sent back
beautiful great Intel reports and I sent
them up to headquarters we had a
kwm2 alpha of uh high frequency net with
one-time pads and I was a ditty bopper
back then wow so it was CW was using
Morse code yes and uh and they were
delighted
until the Ambassador got called in
because one of the people had been
captured and interrogated and he spilled
the beans on everything including this
Lieutenant Doucet that was non-existent
and so
anyway make a long story short I got a I
got an Urgent Message from headquarters
saying
Doucet must leave and be as far away for
as long as possible
and so um and they called me back in the
train yeah basically disappear I went up
there and they said you are hereby
sentenced to i-core
and I said okay three bags full and went
over and talked to people about what was
available
and they said well we've got this one
organization called command and control
North
and uh I said okay what do they do it's
intelligence collection I said okay sign
me up
and that's how I wound up going up to
CCN
interestingly enough the day that I
arrived there was the day that Jack
Warren
had everybody out on the oh on the
helipad right around January 1st 1960
yeah somewhere right right around there
and uh he had the body bags of of a
Recon team three three Americans from uh
I forget the team's name right now but
yeah they had gone out uh Halls Hall and
uh
I forget the third third American
but uh and the audience lived and they
had a friend that was like another
psychological aspect of that case but so
the body bags are there Colonel Warren
comes out and this is your welcome to
CCN yeah and he's dipping his hands in
the body bag and holding up entrails and
shaking them at us and lecturing us
about you know apparently what happened
was they just got lacks they were
waiting for x-fill and you know they
declared an index and and uh all sat
down and started smoking and joking and
an NBA Patrol walked right through the
middle of them
and uh and then left the bodies so and
they may have had a couple drinks
celebrating New Year's Eve
surely no no no no SF no no never did
not on Mission yeah but halls I went
through combo training with he'd been he
came in from Canada he was a Canadian
but he was SF fully with us and uh one
of the good men that went down that day
wow and that's your introduction that
was the introduction I'm standing there
trying to figure out you know where I'm
going to sleep tonight and and I'm
having in trail Shake shaking at me it's
a mandatory formation yeah mandatory
formation and then that
uh got over with and uh and it was like
okay now what and we all went down to
the club and yeah had a drink and who
was it was it speedy Gaspard or
Bill Angel no because I think before
Speedy came in but
turned around and cold decked somebody
who was sitting next to him and just
laid him out flat on the floor you know
and Bill Angel was a major fellow Angel
what happened it was the XO at fob4 that
became CCN at that time what have I
gotten myself into you know these guys
are lunatics
so I got a son I got assigned to
um the S2 shop
and uh since I was known as an Intel
weenie indeed and so uh I went in there
and started you know doing this too
stuff
and um
then I had an opportunity I had learned
a little bit about
um
tapping into Communications bar tapping
yes indeed what I call the black bag yes
and so um
I uh I
I had a little trip over to NSA and got
some equipment from them and came back
and you had new state-of-the-art
equipment at that time yeah which was
different than what we had recently had
the little cassette but the wires but
yours was more state-of-the-art as it
was and it had uh you know a CRT on it
and I could look up one way to see how
far the next Terminus was yeah down the
other ways yeah and then it recorded as
well the trouble was one you had to find
a wire
and two you had to attach to it and then
you left the little bag or or whatever
and and um waited for it to fill up with
stuff that you could take back and I
don't know how many missions we ran with
that but we never did hit a wire no we
would look at it on the photos yeah and
there's darn wire you can see it you can
see it strung along the trees and so on
like that and uh then we get on the
ground and we'd go and and there was no
wire
really just disappeared yeah I know
there were several successful operations
uh other people had but um I never
tapped them during the course of a
regular Mission twice
up in Laos and one time they Sal would
go up the pole tapped in covered the
wire down the pole with mud yeah and we
sat there and we had an ambush set up
and then later we had to leave and we
just pulled it down yeah same same later
and the CIA told us
even if you can't hear anything tape
because we will amplify it a hundred
times because the NBA phones when you
put them in the Cradle they still work
ah and that's what is like to us that's
strange because you know in the US you
close to put your phone in the Cradle
it's done you don't hear anything but
there they didn't have sophisticated
equipment that beltail had and so we
tapped but in your case you're prepared
yes they do art equipment ready to go
and
never got the wire so then uh you
somehow you and Lynn black connected in
March of 69 I'm near the end of my Tour
of Duty as a team 1-0 for Idaho and they
came up with this mission for a mugia
pass and we and we Lynn goes we got to
get captain o'burn on this mission for
our tactical and uh that we we trained
up for that mission for a little bit
extra time extra weapons
you know that was crazy right oh yeah
yeah totally crazy this is a major route
out of North Vietnam
feeding down into the Ho Chi Minh trail
through mugia past they wanted us to go
sit up on the edge of the pass and call
in reports as convoys were cutting
through right because then I guess they
were going to come bomb them or
something but well you know we had the
mission and it got canceled at the last
minute as we were on the helicopters
heading north and they canceled the
mission because another aircraft got
shot down over that Target and for a
sidebar on that
at the reunion soar I don't know four or
five years ago I'm talking to cleat
sinyard who will be our next guest on
our SOG podcast
um cleat was there he came to me said
you know your pictures in the book from
on the ground the picture you guys are
getting inspected what was that mission
I said we were going to go up to mugia
pass he goes oh that mission says they
try to get us a go up there we said no
it was a suicide mission
yeah
this is true yeah so we never had that
intercommunication you don't learn this
until 45 years later yeah I think I had
a a high freak radio with me a little
Delco 5300 you had some extra special
stuff I forgot what it was now because
uh but we were going to go in heavy with
a five-man team with five or five of our
ditch and uh with buku whatever so we're
fortunate my friend indeed
that's why we're here today yes indeed
so I go home Lynn black takes over Idaho
you go back to S2 and at some point you
wind up working with the hatchet force
and later become the 1-0 for one of the
best Recon teams in Camp which was RT
Rhode Island yeah Rhode Island
um
Dan Thompson who was briefing with me
today right
um was the 1-0 of Rhode Island before I
took it and
um
I forget exactly what the circumstances
were where the the 1-0 slot came open
but they said yeah we'll take him
Meadows was down at uh was the commander
per Recon company that's a Recon company
this is the legend dick mattos who when
he was a CCC as an enlisted sergeant
set of wreck world record for 12 pow
snatches out of Contour
oh pow snatches yeah you remember that
there was a crazy time well yeah and we
always had that for us even in 68 was if
you get a pow you got the 100 bonus in
five days oh yeah and then later they
jacked it up yeah it became 30 days
conus yeah r r you know I forgot I
couldn't avoid that everybody wanted to
go so dick Meadows did such a good job
there he had a direct commission to a
captain yeah then he wound up as a
captain to Recon company and when I left
he was a captain so that's what we were
talking about here one of our SOG
Legends as Captain Recon and the rest
you wind up on the RT Idaho at Rhode
Island wasn't he uh on loan from uh
first Special Forces Group
I don't know that's above my pay grade I
just knew that he was there and it's
like one of our Legends kind of like
he's amazing absolutely amazing sure
okay so then I I want to take an over
um Rhode Island
and uh we ran a couple of missions the
one that I just briefed on at the which
is kind of a noteworthy because he
talked a little bit about a bright light
how
you you start out with planning for one
Mission you're actually at the launch
site right at the launch site within
hours of launch to go in on a black bag
and
um
and all of a sudden we get a call we got
a bright light get ready
so we had to get rid of all the extra
Ash and trash and the the black bag and
so forth like that and
um I think it was 25 minutes from the
time that we got the call like 16 35.
and until till we got on the on the
Choppers heading towards the mission and
then you know it was 30 minutes to get
there and
15 minutes to get us on the ground
and then right just just for our
listening audience for those who are not
familiar with a bright light there are
different missions within SOG but the
most dangerous by far was a Bright Light
Mission because that mission's design
uh where a Recon team will go in to help
another team that's in distress or
overrun or for down Pilots or sometimes
there would be a plane crash and we had
to go in to try to get recover any
critical instruments Intel paperwork
that was from the aircraft and people
and people yeah and they were by far the
most dangerous because after a team
would be in trouble or plane crash the
NBA knew that we were coming back and so
bright light you went in heavy with ammo
extra hand grenades uh body bags maybe a
canteen of water bandages no food
because you knew you're going to be in
and shot out the only question was how
long could you get the mission done in
your case you did the whole thing but
it's dramatic talk about it how you get
on the ground and what you're
discovering oh and what what triggered
the bright light Mission the team was
yeah
RT Missouri right which was
um
three Americans and five of the endage
right the little people the little
people that we officially call little
people because that's right yes I think
they were tahan or or yeah I forget
anyway so
um they were going after the PW snatch
you know that oh yeah
bright symbol that's sitting off in the
distance of 30 days on on the beach at
Waikiki or we dreamed about that yeah
and uh so they had gotten themselves
inserted and
um were up under the triple canopy
below an NVA camp that was
sort of on one of these high crested
Hills
a couple hundred meters from the the
base of it where there was a stream up
to the to the peak of it and just before
the military crest
there was an NVA camp that was sitting
there so the team had gotten in they got
in without being uh discovered which is
kind of amazing I never did find out
where their original
Landing Zone was but they may have
walked for a while to get there anyway
they got there they got up close they
got to the point where they were
observing what was going on
and they called for aerial rocket
artillery which is uh you know Cobra
Cobra gunship eight inch rocket
artillery basically and um
they didn't have a good position fix on
the team
they thought they had a good position
fix on the camp
anyway Captain Cheney who was the uh the
1-0 of of Missouri called for them to
fire
and they fired a barrage of the eight
inch and it came down in the trees right
above the RT oh
and
um that that must have been horrendous
um
so the three Americans were were Captain
Cheney
um Sergeant
um
Williams I think it was no Williams was
on the bright light yeah he was on the
bright light uh Wilson yeah and
specialist Mallory was the one too
and um
uh each one of them got hit
and uh one of the
one of little people had a sucking chest
wound and the others were all you know
miscellaneous well one of the Americans
had the top part of his skull missing
yeah that was Maori yeah but we didn't
discover that and when the first call
came in a lot of confusion leading up to
this Mission uh they didn't know where
they were
they didn't know exactly how many people
they had because we're hearing from
Wilson who is completely paralyzed
except for his
for his right arm which is holding the
radio the irk10 which is he's talking
yeah talking upstairs to somebody and
that's what triggered the bright light
so we get in there and we don't know
where they are we don't know you know
who's who but we brought a stretcher and
we brought the dock because we knew
there was at least one person who was
non-ambulatory
so um
we start heading for what we think is
the correct direction
and we finally get in touch with uh
Wilson on the irk 10. and he kind of con
confirms that we're heading in in the
right way and uh so we get into
you know Patrol mode and start heading
that direction
then suddenly my point man stops
and signals for me to come forward and I
came up to the forward and he says
there's an American up there in a
clearing
so we we looked up in that clearing and
there was specialist Ford Maori and he
was laying on his back spread eagle
and the top of his head seemed to be
missing basically the skull was exposed
but even there if he's spread eagle you
must have thought wait a minute is this
a setup yeah that's what I thought it
was a setup so instead of just rushing
in and checking him out we you know move
around checked out the area cleared it
for
which all took time
sure
found out that Mallory was still alive
and I hope he's still out there
someplace and enjoying life
by the top of a skull missing so now
we've got
now we've got the second non-ambulatory
that we know of right and so that's
Captain Cheney
no this is Maori because the first one
wasn't specified who it was okay you
didn't know what that Wilson was saying
you're still finding people we're still
finding people and um you you saw
Mallory you secured the area yeah
secured the area yeah and then we
started moving and because Mallory was
in an area that that had some open
spaces around it we figured out the
emergency landing Zone should be there
we've only got one stretcher he's the
second you know non-ambulatory so you
know we could at least tug him over to a
helicopter sure so we found a space and
designated that as the emergency LZ
then the rest of us started heading up
and you left a couple cheap troops with
him left two of our four
and didge little people yeah
were there and they provided security
and kept an eye on the LZ and so forth
and so we went back up and as we were
coming up the hill sure
talking to Wilson and he was he was
talking us up he had used a couple of
pen flares to let us zero in on them we
came up and the first person we ran into
was Captain Cheney
and Captain Cheney was face down on the
ground
and uh the back of his uh
uniform was all torn up so he had gotten
a piece of the ARA
and um the shrapnel for new yeah yeah
it's very impressive stuff the way it
chewed up the area deadly uh so I went
over and I talked to him for a little
bit and the rest of the patrol walked
off and and tried to figure out what was
going on Doc came over with me
and this is Doc Williams again doc
Williams the mobile launch Team medic
who came
and um
so we let him be for a while I was going
to start an IV on him and then doc said
nah you don't need to do that
so walked over to where Wilson was and
Wilson was was able to do you know like
this with his arm but that was about it
and he was paralyzed
and so now the count has gone up now we
know we've got two plus Mallory
non-ambulatory and you know
um
then we went up the hill a little
further
and we found one of the the little
people uh who had a sec a sucking chest
wound and it was a good thing that we
had doc there
because he was able to stabilize that
and and uh and the rest of them were all
spread across a line and you know none
of them were there was one that was
unscathed one didn't have a single hit
on him but everybody else was was banged
up one way or the other
so we got everybody together
um still keeping an eye up the hill for
the NVA sure folks who may have been
suitably impressed with the aerial
rocket artillery demonstration that they
decided to go the other direction
I don't know but we want you critical
time whatever yeah
so we uh
first thing I did was I called for some
more stretchers
said you know we we got more people that
we got to carry out
and uh
Huey came in with the stretchers and the
first one dropped and came down through
the trees right where we were beautiful
the second one
took about a quarter mile turn the other
direction and so I said they're probably
using that to the local people yeah they
can do that
so um
now we're set to go and we've got we've
got a a big load
Cheney was you know a big boy
and um Wilson was a little smaller so he
was changed like six two six three two
hundred twenty two hundred thirty pounds
somewhere around there I mean what do
you mean big yeah and heavy big and
there's there's three U.S that are
combat ready
uh on on my team right and then uh we
had two of the little people who were
combat ready there's five people to
carry
all these other folks out
so anyway we got the the little people
hooked up together and we got the one
sucking wound
uh on a stretcher
we got
um Wilson on the stretcher
and while we're doing all this
Captain Cheney groaned loudly rolled
over and kind of slid down the hill
and we rushed over to check on him and
and no pulse
he was he was gone he was in bad shape
as it was sure so anyway
um at that point uh
uh we were ready to pack up we made sure
we got all the weapons we got all the
thank you police the area the rucksacks
and yeah all that stuff so we didn't
leave any Footprints or fingerprints
sure I guess or souvenirs that they
could use yeah and so we started heading
down the hill
and uh that was that was a diff it was
also dark
at by this time night had fallen and you
know so we're going down through this
jungle Hill with you know very steep
slope to it
trying to make it out and we got down to
the stream and was that when we first we
started hearing movement behind us
and you know it could have been water
buffalo who knows or Tigers but they had
hungry tigers that did attack Marines in
South Vietnam yes when you're when
you're in that mode everything is
suspicious and uh and plus your little
people know they can hear yeah and
they're giving you signals already as a
one zero yeah you know go go DDD yeah so
we we headed back towards where Mallory
was it took us
a good 40 minutes
to get the 200 meters from where the the
team was down to to the uh emergency LZ
and we got down there and uh called for
the for the folks to come in and get us
for the extraction yeah and um we got
Doc and
um
uh the bodies
I got them out on the on the first lift
out and as it took off
the hill up above us opens up with AK
fire
thank heavens it wasn't you know
something heavier than that yeah yeah
but um they they got out and they you
know their door gunner opened up and it
was like oh my goodness it's New Year's
yeah and it's night in the New Year's
and night in the new years and we didn't
have nods we didn't have any of that
stuff that was just you know what you
what you see is what you get
so they got out
um second Chopper came in we got that
loaded up got gear and and people on it
and uh it got out and then we went out
on the last last so if you're on your
elz are you using any kind of strobe
light or anything to bring them in or
they're just coming in by sheer guts and
uh night vision from their eyes
adjusting to seeing at night yeah I
don't think they didn't have nods on
there no but you know we we put out some
lights I mean we were just shining
flashlights up at him okay and uh we
were able to get them down but you know
having flown helicopters yes I know how
scary that must have been but these guys
were Rock Solid they just brought it in
brought it to a hover set it down gently
took what we got even when the shooting
started there wasn't any oh you know
they had ice in the ground yeah and
their door gunner was was firing away
and
good stuff
so um
you're down to your third helicopter
down the third helicopter we got packed
up we heard a whistle
and you know how they use the whistles
oh yeah yeah I had one mission where
we got trapped out and and they were
they were trying to force us into an
ambush I'm pretty sure right and uh they
were blowing the whistles and all that
good stuff not a not a good feeling no
because you know they're coming now
they're coming fortunately it was
raining now it's raining on top of it no
no the the other yeah the other Mission
yeah and um it was raining and it was
dark and and they were lazy and we were
able to lay down
behind trees and let them walk over us
and they walked right through us and not
a one of us got got picked up it was a
five-man team so
that was pretty lucky oh yeah that was
that first vietnamese-led team yeah so
another black bag operation going bad
anyway so I digress no no but we're so
yeah back to uh we got them all out
um I think
by the time we touched down back at at
fubai
uh six hours and 45 minutes had had
passed wow so you know I'd use this as
an example of a Come As You Are
sure party because there was no
tailoring planning
anything no info hardly right and you
hadn't nothing from the ground other
than that we got people
shot up by Friendly Fire
oh
so that was it was good but that was
That's a classic example of a bright
light and uh you were able to get in
there with your team of course you're
lucky on your team you had a great
endage and Trung you still had
trungazers your counterpart I think he
was the one who didn't get wounded no
kidding yeah I think he was he was okay
wow and uh and the others were all you
know arms and and leg type stuff but the
legs didn't interfere with their walking
yeah so so it would get everybody out
you get back to the base and so
that's a successful Mission but you did
wet my appetite a little bit you're in
with a five-man team it's night it's
raining and you lay down in the NBA
we're looking for it it just walk
through your perimeter
you didn't give Olivia business card or
anything no well actually this was
supposed to be the
the the first uh lldb run
Recon okay this is when we're trying to
do Americanization I mean uh
Vietnamization yes to get them to take
over all these and so at that period of
time uh in 1969 the term Vietnamization
surfaced and also at that time in early
1969 we had the highest number of
American troops in Vietnam at that time
which was like 543
000 in country
and at the President Nixon was elected
and 68 took office in 69 they talked
about Vietnamization and began scaling
back the war
and they're withdrawing troops and part
of that Vietnamization from the Special
Forces side
was having the
lldakpiet which was the Special Forces
trained indigenous troops who could be
Vietnamese mountain yard or Nung
depending on where you were in the
country what part of the country and so
even in SOG we had teams trained up like
that and so the lldb at that time was
now we're talking later 69 yeah and
you're still with the 1-0 for Rhode
Island yeah well no now I'm I'm I'm a
floater at this point okay and so they
said hey delineate that you uh AKA strap
hanger yes
you know you've worked with these people
why don't you go out with this team as
the liaison because this is a Vietnamese
planned Vietnamese Run Reservation and I
just brought the black bag just in case
sure and so um you never left home
without it I never left home without it
except for a bright light so we got we
got put in and we were like 10
kilometers off of our plan
insertion point 10 10 oh and it was cold
my God that was the coldest I have ever
been in my life once we got up the side
of the karst mountain
um
we uh it started raining early on and so
we're looking for where we're supposed
to be and I figured we need to get up
get a little bit of elevation and get
some High Ground so we can see because
we're coming out of a valley going up
the side of this scarce mountain karst
is like glass
almost it's got you know little Jagged
edges and everything like that all of
our hands were torn up by the time we
got up there one up the side of this
thing found some caves really in the
dark yeah and climbed in the caves and
basically we were out
uh we were so tired from the from the
climb and everything that you know we
didn't even set security being cold and
wet being cold and wet just takes it
right out of you and at one point did
you know or suspect that the bad guys
the NVA are looking for you have you
heard any any any uh I skipped crackers
okay yeah that's why that's why we're
back on point while we were walking
around down there in the valley in the
valley yeah
we started hearing these whistles oh
again and uh this was this was the start
of the of the whistle thing and it
seemed like it was a linear
set up we could hear them you know
across a line like that so the the first
thing you think about is they're trying
to push you someplace sure so that's
where you don't want to go
so this is alongside the valley and so
that's why I decided to cut across and
to go up the side of the mountain in
order to get up to where I could see
where we were supposed to be
so anyway we we got out there I
suggested to the young Lieutenant the
lldb lieutenant that it might be a good
idea not to go the way they're trying to
push us
and he agreed and so we came up with
this idea because we had some scrub
trees and so forth there that if we
would lay down
on our back with our rifle in her hand
and let them walk
that the worst that could happen would
be they might find one of us and you
know start shooting and
you know there was no plan beyond that
we were cold and wet and
so we we did that we laid out there they
walked right through US blowing their
whistles we saw them go by they didn't
have any lanterns they
any dog no dogs no dogs no dogs
we were lucky on that one and they just
they walked through us and kept going oh
I wonder what they thought where did
they go oh my God so you know after we
gave them about 100 yards or so we got
up and and motioned off to the to the
north
and went up the side of the karst
mountain found the caves and said yeah
we're done and uh that you know I regret
that because we should have had security
and so forth but you know nobody was in
shape he just had the NBA walk over you
all without a shot fired
talk about hide and go seek Too Close oh
my God Mike so then we were up there in
the
in the Upper Hills yeah and uh all of
our hands were cut up and everything and
and uh so we went off and tried to find
the wire we couldn't find the wire the
invisible wire they had uh they had an
F4 shot down in the valley
that was not far away or shot up uh I
don't remember whether there was an
ejection or not
but anyway it was time to get out of
town
and so we called in the an extraction
and we were up on a on a not a pinnacle
but we had a Ledge
out like that there was no place for a
helicopter to land up on where we were
so they brought in an h-34
and the a34 is you know that beautiful
Workhorse oh yeah Pilots are crazy yeah
King B King B come okay
and um so we were able to get everybody
out
on the edge and they could jump over to
the crew compartment and get in there
and and so forth the king we had two the
two steps so you can land on a step and
get in yeah and I'm standing there and
then there's some shooting going on and
the h-34 starts to move away and I
jumped out and grabbed onto the wheel
really unfortunately the crew chief
reached out and grabbed me by the back
of the pack and and pulled me in but
that was that was the end of that fun
thing and when we got back to base the
uh the Vietnamese colonel uh whooped up
on that young lieutenant
because you know he felt like he didn't
do a very good job oh my God he came
back alive yeah with you with me
so that that was about it for for then
and I was very short at that point right
been trying to get into flight school
because as we all know laying out there
in the wet in the cold and the in the
jungle at night and watching those
airplanes fly over those guys are going
to go back to a hot meal
you know nice air-conditioned Hooch and
with the Airborne command centers went
over with the c-130s we always said well
tonight are they having caviar with
their champagne or are they doing
fillets I'm sorry yeah yeah so that you
know I finally got my orders to to come
home
and to go to flight school they sent me
to the Mi Advanced course at that point
at Fort Holland which is military
intelligence Military Intelligence
indeed and uh so I went through that for
a while and then
um
right after that I went to flight school
but it was delayed almost up to the to
the graduation date of the Mi uh
Advanced course because
there was a problem with my medical
and so is that psychological or after a
tour of Duty and song let me tell you
the they uh they had a small Clinic
there at Fort Holabird and um
there was a problem and and they called
from from uh the surgeon general's
office and said you know we've got a
problem we need to run this test again
and so I said yeah okay what do you want
me to go down to the clinic and we'll
tell them what we want
so I go down to the clinic
and um there's there's this older lady
who was the the nurse there
and she said oh yes uh cat no burn we
know
um take this slide and she cleans a
little slide and hands it to me and she
said go into the bathroom
and milk your penis down and whatever
you get put on the slide and bring it
back to me
and I'm thinking oh my God what the hell
did I bring back from Vietnam so we did
that and the results went off I got
another call from the surgeon general's
office and they said
we don't understand the results of this
test you got to go down there and get it
done again
so I go back down there and they'll tell
you why no see the lady and she says uh
I got to repeat it huh yeah okay so we'd
go through that again send it off again
and it comes back again as
doesn't make any sense and no idea what
triggered it no idea and of course my
mind's just spinning on this thing and
so they say go back down to the clinic
and have the lady call us
and we'll talk to her and so I go back
down and and they talk and she starts
laughing
she thought this was great Sport and um
so she says okay roll up your sleeve
wait a minute roll up my sleeve she said
from my penis to my sleeve yeah okay the
man said he won a thick smear which is a
test for residual malaria
and she said I thought he said he wanted
the dick smear
that's so
so we got the bloody English we got the
we got the blood test done and uh and I
got orders for flight school shortly
thereafter
so I went and the Army didn't want to
have any more
fixed Wing only pilots and Mi only had
fixed-wing airplanes oh really so at
that time yeah yeah so they said okay
you're gonna have to go through
helicopter school first so Fort Walters
Texas don't throw me into that Briar
Patch learning how to do the Huey and
all that good stuff yeah
and then after I graduated just back up
a little bit I mean I've read the book
chicken hawk talking about Apollo's
first-hand experience about learning how
to fly a helicopter and during my time
in nam I spent time in the co-pilot seat
with the King bees I could almost take
off but the controls are so delicate oh
yeah I mean aren't there a couple little
scenarios where you're like your first
time trying to hover or just to take off
without crashing it's great great fun to
watch the pilots try to learn to hover
the first time oh the Lord you know and
and you've got the collective yes guys
the throttle built into it so right you
know that that's the pitch in the blades
that makes you go up and down indeed you
got the Rudders which control two pedals
on the floor and then you got a stick
the cyclic which sort of aims it and so
you have to learn how to coordinate all
of those together right in order to take
off for land and just for our listening
audience sake
people don't realize how sensitive
that particularly the cyclic is because
you when you see movies with people
flying airplanes you see them moving the
hands up and down turning and with a
helicopter with a cyclic you just think
about where you want to go barely ever
touching it yeah correct depending on
what's that like Yeah Yeah
from age 34 to a modern day helicopter
for sure yeah
but you learned all that learned all
that and then had to go to fix Wing
school and unlearn how to hover because
fixing airplanes don't hover oh no yes
that's true Cessna 172 ease which were
souped up and great and finally got
there almost almost flunked out because
I couldn't quite stop trying to hover it
on a short final and uh finally got
through that and then the next orders
were to go to
um multi-engine
really and then after multi-engine and
instrument I went to the Mohawk
transition the ob1 Mohawk oh yeah of
course which is a military intelligence
plane sure so ugly sin oh beautiful it's
lovely ejection seats oh man anything's
going on Morgan I just pulled a little
ring and you're out and I'm out I'm back
Airborne again so uh went through that
um
and then they tried to send me back to
Vietnam to go to a mohawk unit which was
the 131st which was the last Mohawk in
and and at this time
you know you were talking about how many
troops were there sure this is 72 and
they're down to like under a hundred
thousand yeah more like over two years
yeah sure and uh and not combat units no
no mostly support units so it got over
there and they said okay uh we can send
you the 131st to be the property book
officer
and the unit is leaving Vietnam in a
couple of months
and I said hmm property book
accountability leaving
[Music]
no
I said what else she what else she got
and they said well we've got a couple of
air cab units that that could use some
pilots and you are rotary Wing qualified
right I said of course
so they sent me to uh D troop 17th cab
17th 17th cabin okay and this was at Da
Nang and um so I was there for a couple
of months we participated in the 1972
Spring counter-offensive right and flew
in that the Easter offensive the Easter
offensive that's the NBA came in
and uh so I you know
that was a beautiful scene going up
Highway one and oh I can't imagine and
seeing that that five mile long Convoy
that was destroyed by the NVA tanks that
were sitting up on a ridge above it
bodies still there and all that yeah no
kidding that was that was cool but um
and then I wound up in Okinawa on a
Medevac and uh
about on a Medevac so what happened to
you that required a Medevac sir we got
hit with we while you're flying while
we're flying yeah in a in dropping off a
Vietnamese Marine unit division or
something yeah for the counter-attack
and um uh took a piece of shrapnel in
the scrotum oh any brain damage no
that's one of those that that hurts more
than any other place you can get hit oh
you're just about and it was like
get me home get me home
thank you to a pecker Checker yeah so
um we made that out got out they sent me
to Okinawa
the sanitary conditions are not
uh adequate we'll send you over to
Okinawa and that way you can do your
your recovery recovery there and then
and then come on back and I did I went
on back and um
and at that point they had an opening in
F Troop
of the eighth cab
which was also up at Da Nang
and um so I went over there and they
needed a scout platoon leader and I said
oh this is right down my line I get to
do Recon this is the oh six you know the
little tadpole no sure oh yeah flying
around at Treetop looking for Footprints
and so forth so uh wound up with them we
and one of their tactics too was that
you had two or three and the first one
would be bait and the second word of
fossil you're not supposed to know that
I know but that was a pink team I think
a white team was one
1086 one Cobra and one uh Huey as the
command and control right so we would go
out and play this game called pin the
map
pin the map pin the map so you would
head into a suspect area right until you
ran into air defense
and then you'd Mark the Spot on your map
or the eight the command and control
ship would Mark the Spot and you'd get
out as best you could and somebody in in
Saigon would stick a pin in the map
and um so then they'd give it a a couple
of days and they'd come in from a
different direction
and they'd stick another pin in the map
when you get shot out of there and then
you come around the other way and come
in like this what they're doing is just
basically setting up the boundary
of a whatever area is worthy of having
air defense
put up with it wow and so um
we did that we we finished and and so
also at that time just for a point of
reference
I mean when Johnson declared the end of
the bombing Hall and at the end of 68
the NVA began bringing a lot of their
anti-aircraft Weaponry South so three
years later when you're coming up
against you're coming up against
everything from 37 Mike Mike 57 Mike
Mike is something even bigger probably
which I forget what that nomenclature is
but the the 12-7 was the one that they
used the most in in 12 7 is a 50 caliber
equivalent yeah 50 caliber but still
very effective anti-aircraft weapon oh
yeah
site on the front with all that good
stuff yeah so we ran into a couple of
those and and escaped them and um
yeah so um
let's see lost my Chain of Thought but
you're talking about then they bring in
points a B-52 in the Box okay and they
they'd be 52 it to to mess and then
they'd send us back in to see what we
found to do an aerial BDA bomb damage
assessment
and uh because there wasn't anybody else
going to do a BDA out there
we did that and on one of these missions
coming back after we had stuck a pin in
the map we were coming back and and
typically you never fly straight in
level any place
so I'm juking around back and forth like
that
and all of a sudden Bam Bam Bam I get
hit three times
one of them came through the the canopy
one of them came through
the the chin bubble and through my right
foot and then one of them went in in the
back and hit the bleed air band on the
engine
and so uh I couldn't figure out why I
was in a in a crab
I wasn't you know because you you
control the direction with the rudder
pedals right
and you know I'm I'm
leaning right right forward front and um
I looked down and the top of my boot was
like a big flower oh I had taken a 12-7
AP
that had come up and gone through my
foot and out the other side
and uh that's why I walk funny these
days yeah no wonder so uh oh my God
so that was the end of uh Vietnam for me
we flew it for a while I got my crew not
crew chief he was the Gunner who sat
behind me right
to come out through the side of the
helicopter across the minigun and get in
the pilot seat and we took the extra
cyclic stick out and stuck that in and
got that
that strap down and I you know so I said
this is just in case something happens
and and I'm not able to fly you're going
to have to fly it aren't you bleeding a
little bit from a from a 12.7 amazing
amazingly not no it was a clean it was a
hot shot or something oh it got seared
yeah
it uh
yeah anyway oh my God nice foot yeah
so talk about a Lead Foot so we've we
flew back for a while and uh we had been
operating out of a base near Nui Badin
sure the big black virgin mountain right
and I can see this off in the distance
and so I'm just you know heading for the
barn and the other guys are all
following me
and then the engine started feeling a
little bit wonky and uh so I I put it
down in uh in an arc light site a B-52
strike site that you know pretty well
cleared off all the the terrain there
was one tree and I made my approach to
the tree and was able to get it down and
and uh without crashing without crashing
another bird came in and and the CNC
bird picked me up
we went out and you're officially being
medevactive act on my way that was
purple heart number five number five
number five
oh so
oh my God okay so
from there you get Medevac they take it
to the now you go back to Okinawa again
so you can stay close
now this time they decided to operate
there in in uh Saigon
and uh
yeah I can I can remember the dock with
a wire brush going through you know back
and forth on that through the bull hole
in your foot hole you know scrubbing
that up they both give you any
anesthetic first no because when I when
we got to the intermediate base near 10
uh near uh Nui Badin yeah
um they were evacuating me back and they
did you need anything I said yeah I need
a drink of water so I got a nice bottle
of water drank that down and when I got
there for the guys to operate on me they
said have you had anything to eat or
drink in the last hour
and I said yeah
had some water
on the Medevac Chopper and they weren't
too happy about that but anyway they
said you know we can't put you under
so they had this pretty little nurse
come and stand right next to me
and uh so I couldn't make noises or
anything like that and so we got through
it you know
so I literally had to sew you up they
yeah
they shipped me out of there they
shipped me to
um
where do we go I remember we were in
Texas
landed at Lachlan base or something like
that and switched over aircraft spent
the night in the hospital there and then
they they sent me forward
and I wound up
um
at uh Fort Meade Maryland
oh in the hospital there yeah and we had
a little bit more cutting and sewing and
all that and then they they just sent me
home it was around Christmas time and
so that was this is Christmas 72 then
yeah wow
and so at that point are you close to
getting re thinking about re-enlisting
or which way am I going am I going to be
a helicopter pilot am I going to be an
intelligence officer or
now it
I'd finished the advanced course and um
you know I was a senior captain at this
point and uh the one thing that the
combat arms loved
to see in and support people was the CIB
and and the purple hearts on your record
and prove you've been there
and so uh uh I got stationed at uh Fort
Huachuca Fort Huachuca Arizona lovely
place man I love that place what are you
doing Halo jumps back then there no no
that's today's okay
I went to combat developments commands
and and worked on some electronic stuff
and so forth for a couple years and then
after that
um
uh I got orders to go to Germany and I
went over as the S3 of
uh what did we call it uh
aerial exploitation Battalion which was
A New Concept that took
ru-21s you know doing radio stuff and uh
ob1's doing photo and radar
and and work them and photo
interpretation put that all into one
unit so what's a UV 21
are you 21. are you all sorry what is
that that's uh King Air
oh and uh it's set up with uh intercept
positions and so forth in it so
you know you go up there and listen to
the radio all day which which ASA had in
Vietnam they had agents that were
trained in North Vietnamese they'd fly
over North Vietnam layoffs Listen to
listen in I think they had they
developed incredible intelligence from
those guys yeah I think they had the
ru's over there
okay so here you are you're gonna but
you're gonna operate in Europe Behind
Enemy Lines maybe so just fly over no no
no this is just straight out you know
regular straight leg infantry sure type
support and uh we would go out and fly
air shows every once in a while with the
or I'm sorry I forgot
halfway through this uh I got assigned
as the commander of the 73rd Mi company
aerial surveillance which was the ob1
rv1 company oh wow Obi ones for
reconnaissance sure you know radar photo
um so forth and uh the RV ones were
electronic reconnaissance
and that was great I had 30 airplanes
said 300 people this was a nice size
30-year company
they're busy
a lot of stuff oh yeah got a lot of a
lot of time in
um I used to always fly the the midnight
missions or whatever to during the
holidays so that people could be home
with their families
my wife didn't think very much of that
but yeah but your men appreciate it yeah
absolutely so I remember one flight when
I was up with the standardization pilot
all units have these guys they they are
the gods of making sure you're you're
your acts together yeah we don't want to
say have your together and we used
to fly the re the border around East
Germany and and so forth and uh we would
do it on an autopilot
we set it locked in because you couldn't
hold the the plane still enough for a
radar signal to to be coherent
when it was scanning so we put it on
this flight director machine really and
we fly it and and it was great because
you could sit there and you know smoke
and joke
and all that while you were monitoring
the instruments just to make sure you
were good and uh all and this was in the
dark all my stories are in the dark
and I noticed that my dog tags are
snaking their way up through my flight
helmet
and um that could be an indicator of
some trouble it is but there was no feel
to it I mean you're strapped down tight
in the ejection seat and everything yeah
and you know maybe if we had ashtrays in
it and they'd all emptied out that would
have been a clue but this was my dog
tags and uh we had gone inverted
On the Border I don't know what we were
shooting radar of at that point but whoa
you know and um
so Ernie the Sip pilot with me said oh
gotta go home so we punched it off of
the flight director and then flew it
back manually but uh that was fun
there's all kinds of fun stuff
like that's like it sounds like a
Twilight Zone scenario just flying along
with the greatest of Ease on full
automatic pile all of a sudden without
realizing the aircraft had done 180. I
wasn't watching the The Horizon
indicator oh yes you know that little
problem probably chit chatting or
something that's not that important
right now no the airplane feels fine you
know there's no sweating the engines
aren't roaring or anything they're just
we're just inverting now yeah
we had a had a couple of the Mohawks
crash because when we were flying up
there in the in the in the weather uh
ice would form on the front of the pro
the spinner out in front of the props
right and it would make a big donut
oh and so here you are flying in the
middle of the night and all of a sudden
you hear Wham like that because the
chunk of ice had come off slid down hit
a blade and got thrown against the side
of the cockpit and then a couple times
it broke off and went into the engine
and then the airplane Susan Mohawks in
Europe in Europe yeah yeah okay we
dropped one on on a German Farmer's Barn
that had his his five Mercedes-Benz or
whatever
yeah we were we were uh we had a lot of
fun with that airplane oh little
scenarios you never think about yeah
so after that
um
I said yeah not be as a result of the of
the the thing it was more
we were at a point where uh Jimmy Carter
was the president Who and the budget was
cut back drastically and I didn't have
enough money to
to to get parts
regular parts and keep my Pilots so your
flight line of 30 gets cut back you lose
aircraft and Manpower no we just had
hanger Queens we had no planes that we
couldn't get repair parts for I mean we
had a a wonderful maintenance section
but they just
you know you can't install what you
don't have well it reminds me of 2015.
before the election in 2016 when you had
the Marine Corps going to museums and
even Army Aviation going to museums to
get parts for aircraft because the
budgets have been cut yeah
that's just
that's the story for another day sir but
anyway so you're just I said that the
peanut farmer is in and you're out
that's it I I resigned yeah and uh it
was it was time for me to rotate back
anyway so I just went ahead and resigned
and and then went into the reserves
as a backup but and whereabouts
um
let's see I think I
I think I separated at Dover Air Force
Base that's where they did my out
processing and then I went down to
Atlanta
and uh went looking for a civil service
job
and I got a job as a gs12 at forces
command at Fort McPherson really which
is now a movie studio by the way oh no
really yeah and I work work for the
Deputy Chief of Staff for intelligence
yeah uh at forces command
and stayed there for a while but the
plan had always been to try to find
something that would let me go a little
bit higher yeah yeah so I found a job at
the assistant chief of staff for
intelligence in the Pentagon really and
uh so I applied for that and moved up
there as a GS
so you get a promotion too yeah and the
new better job in the Pentagon the
puzzle Palace yeah and then work that
for a while and then uh
did a lateral over to a job on the
deputy secretary of defense's staff
the uh what do we call that office
I forget breeder General Walt yaiko used
to run it and and it was responsible for
special projects and and stuff that's
still special prize within DOD yeah and
so back then was the
A dia begin to Gear Up
are you doing support for those folks or
just others this was a project this was
interagency stuff that's still okay
pretty classified indeed so uh I went in
there as the deputy director as a 14 and
then
um keep getting promotions all along the
way oh yeah yeah well this is over a
several periods it's every year period
yeah still pretty impressive though okay
you're a gs-14 now you went to DIA uh to
take a job as a 15. naturally
um
and then a couple years later got a
promotion to ses1
over on the uh Deputy Chief of Staff for
intelligence
so when when you're in the assistant
secretary of defense for intelligence
okay because when you're at DIA was that
still basically the intelligence side
were you doing anything from the plw Mia
doc at all that was separate no okay I'm
starting her up go ahead that's quite
all right yeah another another promotion
and another detail and then I wound up
eventually as an ses3
really the director of intelligence
operations which was an empty title
right uh but where for the uh
assistant secretary of defense for
intelligence
still in the Pentagon yeah and then
after a while I'd had enough of that it
was time to retire my mandatory
retirement from the reserves came up and
I thought well this is a good time to go
I had taken
my res my military time right and added
it to my civil service time and uh so
that let me retire as a as an sc ses3
with a pretty good monthly oh so all
that good training that Lynn black and I
gave you on RT Idaho really just um came
back in
[Laughter]
so you reached so what year do you
officially retire from the National
Guard and your your SES three
15 position 1995. wow
well you still got time for another
career what happened next so then I
moved down to Key Largo Florida
and uh taught scuba diving
and civilian now are you working with a
couple of military agencies that do that
stuff in your spare time too civilian
okay this is fun stuff okay and um
uh ran a charter boat and uh worked at a
dive Resort and had a great time and
then I got bored bored again and so I
went off to start working on my PhD
and
um just in anything it was it turned out
to be leadership but uh not to be
confused with educational leadership Oh
indeed it's just leadership yeah and
where does a school that teaches that or
is that one of those in-house deals uh
this was the University of Central
Florida oh okay and they hired me as a
Adjunct professor they teach you then
they trained you and hired you well or
you just went this was at the same time
it's just part of their program to keep
people at home oh so you're learning and
you're teaching at the same time oh very
good okay I want to make sure I had that
screen and that's where I met my wife
okay Samantha
she I like to tease her she
took one of my courses right because we
needed to have 18 bodies
or else the course wouldn't go because
it didn't really make enough Revenue
sure and so I had 17 and I talked her
into taking class
and so
so we got married and um
and then uh eventually had my son Connor
who is now a specialist fourth in the
310th psyop Battalion his work in sciops
makes you proud got a little lineage
going here
and uh we live in Gainesville
at least it's a Gainesville post office
but we're on the Forsyth County side of
Lake Lanier got a house on the lake and
this is floridia this is Georgia Georgia
yeah okay you missed a transition there
I'm trying to keep up with you Mike we
had a hurricane come through and and
mess up our house we lived at uh on
Merritt Island and that was in Florida
right and uh so she we decided that you
know we didn't want to be targets for
hurricanes so she wanted to move up to
where her parents were yeah they lived
down on Roswell which was uh
close into Atlanta
and I wanted to be on the water and so
the only thing that was around was uh
Lake Lanier which is which is a mud hole
and I used to teach scuba down there uh
limited visibility scuba basically we
did search and Recovery training down
there because that's you got one foot of
visibility maybe you're lucky
how do you find anything
uh there's a method
I bet method yeah okay you stick a stake
in with a rope on it and then you swim
around at the end of the rope and then
you let it out five feet and then you
can swim do it again yeah do it again
until you run on a rope or you find what
you're looking for and then you move the
stake and start it all over so that was
that was that was fun and we've been
there for 15 years and and it's a it's a
Pleasant area don't go down to the lake
much anymore I'm just getting too lazy
that'll hold the foot comes back to
bother you once in a while it certainly
does as you may have noticed today I
noticed a little there but I forgot
why and standing uh gets to be a problem
after a while
so anyway you know I get a check for it
every month there you go yeah
well um looks like we're at that point
um any other Reflections back on some of
your things you did in the military or
any little odd job that we should cover
here before we sign off because the
unique thing is everybody's story is so
different and yours is again it's
another one that we haven't heard and
it's got so many turns and twists to it
I love it I'm biased of course so maybe
not from back in the early Parts but
to the current day yeah
um I belong to a group called The
Phantom Airborne Brigade
that works out of Zephyrhills Florida
and it's a bunch of old retired Airborne
folks
who retired some active duties still
they still have parachutes and uh
they've got a bunch of parachutes I I
purchased my own I've got an mc6 I think
or is it sf2a
got me I remember the mc6 but static
line shoots yeah and so every month they
have a they have a jump our membership
has gone from like 24 members up to 240
really and uh yeah we have some really
big shindigs down there and it's open
you know if you got a 214 that says you
are jump qualified you can come and jump
with us with the LZ sand uh the LZ is
grass nice most of the time yeah but
underneath the grasses soil that can be
pretty hard you mean the concrete no I
had one jump where uh it was right after
a hurricane right
and there was this area of grass
it looked like yeah so I decided to land
in it sure and it turned out to be you
know two feet of water
I got a little wet on that one so did my
shoot but yeah it was you know
I I don't know how many jumps I've got
with them now but it it's been a while
and it's a great group of guys and yeah
if anybody wants to look them up just
you know they've got
phantomareborn.com I think is the is the
website no kidding and so what elevation
are they jumping at uh 1500 normally
yeah because jump school was 1 250 feet
the same height as the Empire State
Building that was the training jump oh
yeah yeah I never knew that yeah that's
that's interesting yeah
um we had uh the last water jump was at
Lake Dora
and that's over a little bit to the to
the east from Zephyrhills and um
they they get the local community
involved in it everybody shows up with
their boat and tries to catch a
parachute or we jump out of a out of a
c-47 the tico Bell and
um that that's great
going out the door of an Old World War
II that was actually a D-Day bird no and
so you know that that's always fun and
then there's also the round canopy
parachute team right it's another group
I belong to basically jumping t10s yeah
oh
people do that to themselves where they
could get a really nice steerable yeah
no I think around rcpts got uh
steerables the yeah the the but the t10s
though they're just like yeah that's
cool yeah you have to pull for half an
hour just to try to get a change in
Direction that's why they jump at 1200
remember when they wanted to do uh
insertions yes daisy chain the little
people
so that you know when the first one went
out he opened the second one and so on
like that so they keep everybody
together yes and uh yeah that 500 foot
jumps are are not fun no no no no no
yeah I at CCN uh during my second tour I
don't know if you had if you had
transferred out yet or not but they were
talking about the whole jump thing and
we didn't know that they had jumped as
early as uh November of 68 they had the
first static line jump which I think
came out of CCC or CCS I know it wasn't
us and uh it's like jumping into layoffs
into Triple Canopy ixnay that was my
first thought but they did it do you
remember the the discussion about a
pallet extraction
you know they'd fly over to cut the
engine come in slow and then toss out
the sh the pilot Chute and it would pull
the team out on a pallet no no
fortunately that one never got never got
tried very good what else was there
um there was they could all die together
in one pilot yeah right you know the
mouse there's gonna be a malfunction
somewhere
and uh
uh there was the 500 foot jump thing
right
um yeah a bunch of this was back when
Dick Meadows was there and and we were
looking at at different things to do
sure
because you all know you don't want to
have a reception committee no we try to
do anything of course it
at that time we knew we were compromised
we just didn't know how badly or so
really we were compromised
and we're going to cover that on our
topic now they have to call you back on
that but you were in there and you were
in the Intel office for a little while
there was there any other indicators
besides the fact that when the sapper
attack came on August 23rd 68 hit the
camp hard they had great Intel and that
we had teams that ran into issues like
Pat Eddington
when his mission was to go to the
American Pow Camp he's in route to the
camp and a guy comes up on the radio
I'm at the camp I know where you're gone
you're Pat Eddington you're from RT
cobra
and it says you got a choice you can
turn around and go home or continue to
the Pow Camp and I will execute every
American here
so Pat Eatonton turned around came back
so our compromise factors were yeah
there was somebody down there in Saigon
that that we had that all the mail and
then we had the uh
um when the North Koreans seized the USS
Pueblo on November 67 they did so at the
Russian behest and when they landed in
Port the Russians came in and took out
all the equipment took it to Cambodia
and then at that point the Johnny Walker
spy ring was starting to sell the the
daily cat codes and stuff
to the Russians
and so they combined them they had their
insights into our Intel highest
Communications for a few years before
they realized it yep it's scary and
still we got stuff done
only by the grace of the Lord or
somebody looking over our shoulder there
so any final thoughts sir as we close
down I want to thank you for taking time
from uh today we by the way we were
recording a third Special Forces Group
and the third quarter third of the third
here at Fort Bragg North Carolina in the
middle of a SOG symposium
and uh but thank you for taking time any
final thoughts closing out here Mike Go
Army
and uh with that
um we want to as always we thank today's
military the service members the Border
Patrol
our First Responders the people that are
working at the hospitals during this
coveted virus and are even our Educators
now that seem to be are the parents of
Educators that are on the front line
fighting for freedom in America
um we also thank the women and the men
and women who served our country years
past are heroes men like Mike o'burn Who
besides being a good friend was one hell
of a soldier we thank him and last but
not least we remember and salute the men
and the women who are still missing and
actually couldn't be here today
and we also close out we thank Jocko
willink productions for making this all
possible
and we will be back with episode number
17 soon thank you God bless America
get your covet shot
not yet I've gotten both in a booster
and you're alive I'm gonna live forever
on that note we are signing off